physics
as a discipline
has a number of problems associated with
me as a chemist it's kind of interesting
that assembly theory and i'm really
you know i want to maintain some some
credibility in the physicist size but i
have to push them because they're
physics
is a really good discipline it's it's
reduced the number physics is about
reducing the belief system but they're
down to some things in their belief
system yeah which is kind of really
makes me kind of grumpy number one is
requiring order at the beginning
universe magically we don't need that
the second is the second law well we
don't actually need that
and i this is blasphemous like well in a
minute i'll recover my career in a
second although i think the good the
only good thing about being the regis
chair means i think there has to be an
act of parliament to fire me
[Laughter]
so you know you can always go to lee's
twitter and protest
and i think the third thing is that so
we've got you know we've got the um the
order at the beginning
um second law the second law and the
fact that causation is emergent
right and that time is immersion
carol just turned off this program
i think he believes that it's immersion
so so causation is not that's clearly
incorrect
because we wouldn't exist otherwise so
tight so physicists have kind of got
confused about time
time is a real thing well i mean so look
i'm very happy with the current
description of the universe as physics
give me because i do a lot of stuff
right i can go to the moon with
newtonian physics i think and i can
understand um the the orbit of mercury
with relativity
and so and i can build transistors with
quantum mechanics right and i can do all
this stuff yeah so i'm not saying the
physics is wrong i'm just saying
if we say that time is fundamental i.e
time is non-negotiable there's a global
clock
i don't neither i don't need to require
that there's order been magically made
in the past because that asymmetry is
built into the way the universe
is
so if tom's fundamental i mean
you've been referring to this kind of
an interesting formulation that is
memory
yeah
so uh time time is hard to like put a
finger on like what what the hell are we
talking about well it's just a direction
but memory
is a construction especially when you
have like
think about these local pockets of
complexity these um
non-zero assembly index entities that's
being constructed and they remember
never forget molecules but remember the
thing is i invented assembly theory
um i'll tell you i invented it when i
was a k i mean i the thing is i keep
making fun of myself from a research
group i've only ever had one idea i keep
exploring that idea over the 40 years or
so since i had that idea i used to well
aren't you the idea that the universe
had so it's very kind of hierarchical
anyway go ahead i'm sorry that's that's
very oh that's very poetic yeah um so i
think i came up with assembly theory the
following idea when i was a kid i was
obsessed about survival kits what is the
minimum stuff i would need
to basically replicate my reality and i
love computers
and i love technology or what
technologies can become so i imagined
that i would have basically this really
big truck full of stuff and i thought
well can i delete some of that stuff out
can i have a blueprint and then and in
the end i kept making this making
smaller and got to maybe half a truck
then to a suitcase and then went okay
i'll screw it i want to i want to carry
my entire technology in my pocket how do
i do it and i'm not like a launch into a
steve jobian you know i'm iplayer
i came up with a matchbox survival kit
in that matchbox survival kit i would
have the minimum stuff that would allow
me to interact the environment to build
my shelter to build a fishing rod to
build uh water purification system and
it's kind of like so what did i use in
my box to assemble
in the environment to assemble to
assemble to assemble
and and i realized i could make a causal
chain in my survival kit so i guess
that's probably why i've been obsessed
with assembly theory for so long and i
was just
pre-configured to find it somewhere
and when i saw it in molecules i i
realized that the causal structure that
we say emerges
and the physics kind of gets really
stuck because they're saying that time
you can go backwards in time i mean how
do we let physicists get away with the
notion that we can go back in time and
meet ourselves i mean
that
that's clearly a very
hard thing
to let we physicists would not let
other sciences get away with
that kind of heresy right so why
physicists allowed to get away with it
let's first of all to push back to play
devil's advocate you are clearly married
to the idea of memory
you see in this
again rick from rick and morty way you
see you you have these deep dreams of
the universe that is writing the story
through its memories those these
chemical compounds that are just
building on top of each other and and
then they they find useful components
they can reuse and then the the reused
components
uh create systems that themselves are
then reused and all in this way
construct things
but
when you think of that as memory
it seems like quite sad that you can
walk that back but at the same time it
feels like that memory you can walk in
both directions on that memory in in
terms of time you could walk in both
directions but i don't i don't think
that that makes any sense because
um the problem that i have with
time
being reversible
is that um
i mean i'm i'm just a you know i'm a
dumb experimental chemist right so i
love burning stuff
burning stuff and building stuff
but when i think of reversible phenomena
i imagine in my head i have to actually
manufacture some time i have i have to
borrow time from the universe to do that
i can't when anyone says let's imagine
that we can go back in time or
reversibility you can't do that you
can't step out of time time is
non-negotiable it's happening no but see
you're assuming that time is fundamental
which most of us do
when we go day-to-day but it takes a
leap of wild imagination to think that
time is emergent um no time is not
emergent yeah i mean this is an argument
we can have but i believe
i can come up with an experiment an
experiment that proves that time cannot
possibly be emerging experiment that
shows how
assembly theory
kind of is the way that the universe
produces selection and that selection
gives rise to life
and also to say well hang on
we could allow ourselves to have a
theory that requires us to have these
these statements to be possible
like we need we need to have
order in the past or we can have use the
past hypothesis
um which is order in the past but
as well
okay
and we have to have an error of time we
have to require that entropy
it increases and we have to say and then
we can say look the universe is
completely closed and there's no novelty
or that novelty is predetermined what
i'm saying is very very important that
time is fundamental which means if you
think about it the universe becomes more
and more novel each step it generates as
more states and next step than it was
before that means bigger search
so what i'm saying is that the universe
wasn't capable of consciousness at day
one
actually because i didn't have enough
states
but but today the universe is complex so
it's like how all right all right hold
on a second
now we've pissed off the pan cycles too
okay
no just brilliant sorry i'm
a part of me is just you know joking
having fun with this thing but uh
because you're saying a lot of brilliant
stuff and i'm trying to slow it down
before my brain explodes so because i
want to break break apart some of the
fascinating things you're saying so
novelty
novelty is increasing in the universe
because the number of states is
increasing what do you mean by states so
i think the physicists almost got
everything right i can't i can't fault
them at all i just think there's a
little bit of dog i'm just trying to
play devil's advocate i'm very happy to
be entirely wrong on this right you know
i'm not right on many things at all
but
but if i can make less assumptions about
the universe with this
then potentially that's a more powerful
way of looking at things
if you think of time as fundamental yeah
you can make less assumptions overall
exactly
the time fundamental i don't need to add
on a magical second law because the
second law comes out the fact the
universe is actually there's more states
available i mean we might even be able
to do weird things like dark energy in
the universe might actually just be time
right yeah but then you have to still
have to explain why time is fundamental
because i can give you one explanation
that's simple at a time and say god
you know like just because it's simple
doesn't mean it's
okay you still have to explain god and
you still have to explain time like why
is it fundamental so let's just say
existence is default which means time is
the default so
how did you go from the existence this
is the thing
well look we exist right so let's just
we'll just just take be very we're yet
to talk about what exists means all
right let's list all the way back yeah
yeah okay i think it's very poetic and
beautiful what you're weaving into this
i i don't think this conversation is
even about the assembly
uh which is fascinating and we'll keep
mentioning it assembly index and this
idea
that i don't think is necessarily
connected to time oh i think it is
deeply connected like i can't explain it
yet so you don't think everything you've
said about assembly theory and assembly
index
can still be correct even if time is
emergent so yeah right now assembly
theory appears to work i appear to be
able to measure objects of high assembly
in a mass spectrometer and look at their
abundance and you know all that's fine
right it's a it's a nice if nothing else
it's a nice way of looking at how
molecules can compress things
um
now am i saying that a time has to be
fundamental not immersion for assembly
theory to work no i'm i think i'm saying
that the universe
um it appears that the universe has many
different ways of using time you could
have three different types of time you
could just have time that's
the way i'd think of it if you want if
you want to hold on to emergent time i
think that's fine let's do that for a
second hold on to emergent time
and the universe is just doing its thing
then assembly time only exists when the
universe starts to write memories
through bonds so let's just say there's
rocks running around you know there's
when when the bond happens and selection
starts suddenly
there are there the universe is
remembering causing in the past and
those structures will have effects in
the future so suddenly a new type of
time emerges at that point which has a
direction and i think sean carroll that
this point might even turn the podcast
back on and go okay i can deal with that
that's fine but i'm just basically
trying to condense the conversation and
say hey let's just have time fundamental
and see how that screws with people's
minds why you're triggering people by
saying fundamental why not we just say
like let's say why am i look i'm walking
through the wall why why
why should i grow up in a world where
time ty i don't go back in time i don't
mean i don't meet myself in the past
there are no one there are no aliens
coming from the future right
you know it's just like oh no no but
that's not no no no no that's like
saying
we're talking about biology or like uh
evolutionary psychology and you're
saying okay let's just assume that that
clothing is fundamental people wearing
clothes is fundamental it's like no no
wait a minute
you can't like i think you're getting in
a lot of trouble if you assume time is
fundamental why give me one reason why
i'm getting into trouble time being
fundamental because you might not
understand the origins of this memory
that might be deeper like that this
memory that could be a thing
that's explaining the construction of
these
uh higher complexities better
than just saying
it's uh it's a search
it's it's chemicals doing a search
for
uh
reusable
uh reusable structures that they can
like
then use as bricks to build the house
okay so i accept that so let's let's
let's go back a second because it's a
kind of it is i wanted to drop the time
bomb at this part because i think we can
carry on discussing it for many many
many many many days many months
um but i'm happy
to
accept that it might be wrong but
what i would like to do is imagine a
universe where time is fundamental and
time is emergent
and ask
let's just then talk about causation
because physicists require that
causation so this is where i'm going to
go causation emerges
and it doesn't exist at the micro scale
that clearly is wrong because if
causation has to emerge at the macro
scale life cannot emerge so how does
life emerge life requires molecules to
bump into each other produce replicators
those replicas need to produce polymers
there needs to be cause and effect at
the molecular level there needs to be in
a girded non-aegiric to a negative
transition right at some point
and and
those replicators
have consequence material consequence in
the universe
physicists just say oh you know what i'm
gonna have a bunch of particles in the
box
i'm gonna i'm gonna think about it in a
newtonian way in a quantum way and i'll
add on an arrow time
so i can label things
and causation will happen magically like
well how explain causation
and they can't the only way i can
reconcile causation is having a
fundamental time
because this allows me to have a
deterministic universe that is creates
novelty
and we and there's so many there's so
many things to unpack here but let's go
back to the point you said does can
assembly theory work with emergent time
sure it can but it doesn't give me a
deep satisfaction about how causation
assembly gives rise to these objects
that go that move through time and space
and again what am i saying to bring it
back
i can say
without fear you know take this water
bottle and look at this water bottle and
look at the features on it there's
writing you've got a load of them um i
know that
causal structures gave rise to this in
fact i'm not looking at just one water
bottle here i'm looking at every water
bowl that's ever been conceived of by
humanity
this here is a special
object in fact leibniz knew this you
know leibniz um it was the same time of
newton he kind of got stuck i think
leibniz actually invented assembly
theory it gave soul the soul that you
see in objects wasn't the mystical soul
it is assembly it is a fact there's been
a history of objects related and without
without the object in the past this
object wouldn't exist there is a lineage
and there is conserved structures causal
structures have given rise to those
fair enough and uh you're saying it's
just a simpler view if time
is fundamental and it and it shakes the
physicist's cage a bit right because we
say but i think that
i i just i just enjoy the fact that
physicists are in cages
i would say that you know
lee smolin i don't want to speak for lee
i'm talking to lee about this i think
lee also is an agreement that time is
has to be fundamental but i think he
goes further you know
even in space i don't think you can go
back to the same place in space
i've been to austin a few times now this
is my
i think third time i've been to austin
is austin in the same place no
the solar system is moving through space
i'm not back in the same space
locally i am
every event in the universe is unique
in space and time
you